okay I'm gonna start
um so I'm Talia we're going to be
talking about testing and production
today
um
yeah I'm
I'm excited I've given this talk a few
times before and I I like getting
people's reaction to it I'm also really
happy people are sitting in the front
row so thank you no one ever sits in the
front row at any of my talks and I get
really upset so Kudos thank you
um so I'm Talia I'm a lead developer
advocate for Akamai and I work on the
cloud mostly with lynnode nowadays
um
before I was a Dev Advocate at Akamai I
worked at a very small cloud computing
company you may have heard of it it's
called Amazon web services
and then before I was a Dev Advocate I
was a test engineer for
five or six years so I transitioned from
being a test engineer to being a deaf
advocate
and one of the things that hap I want to
share with you a story something that
happened to me when I was interviewing
for a position when I was a test
engineer
and so this this happened to me pretty
early in my testing career and I was I
was sitting sitting down for this
interview and the interview is going
like really well and
um you know I'm answering all the coding
questions correctly I'm you know running
uh answering answering things as they
come and I'm feeling I'm feeling really
confident in this interview
and the interviewer you know how at the
end of every interview that they ask you
like oh do you have any questions for me
like you know how's it what what can I
answer for you
so I look at the guy and I'm like yeah
how do you
um how do you do your your deployments
like what time do you guys deploy and
like what when's your down time for
staging and you know how to how do
deployments work like when do you
um when does when does each team have
time to test like when do you run
um different deployments and and things
like that and then they said that they
don't have a staging environment they
test in production
and I heard this in the interview and I
was so confused I was like what do you
mean you test in production this doesn't
make any sense to me I was working in
like a pretty big
um pretty big like corporate company at
the time when I was doing this interview
and that company you know you have
Tuesdays and Thursdays between you know
10 a.m and 4 00 p.m that's when they do
builds to staging and you can't use the
environment at that time or you know
staging will be down because they're
doing performance testing or you know
there's like all this stuff that happens
in in staging and I had never heard of
testing and production before and I was
in the middle of this interview and I
was so confused and he could see that I
was confused he was like clearly you've
never heard of this before but
um he had me do something that I want
you all to try now so
I want everybody to think about the last
feature that your team deployed
so you got it you're thinking about like
a something specific that's in
production
okay is it working
right now
in production
how do you know
your users haven't reported anything to
you like your alarms haven't gotten gone
off like no one's been paged you don't
know that your features are working
right you just like you assume
so testing production is the only way to
know that your features are working
right now in production
and so this is this is one of the one of
the main things about testing in prod
it's your testing features in the
environment that your features will live
in so you're not using a dummy
environment like staging you're not
using you know cert or beta or one of
the other a thousand names that they've
come up with you're using production
um and like I'll talk about later in in
this session is
testing in prod doesn't mean you only
test in prod you know there's there's
specific circumstances where you might
not want to do this so
this is one of the big things with
testing and prod is like it's not the
only place you test it's one of the
places that you should be testing
okay so most companies and all the
companies that I had worked for before
this one that I was interviewing for
they all used a test environment or a
staging environment so show of hands who
here uses a test environment okay now
keep your hand up if it's an exact
replica of production exact
okay Liars but fine
um so testing and production is really
it's not the way to go here and there's
a few reasons why so
this is what I've learned like through
my experience as a test engineer so
staging environments are really really
expensive to maintain right they cost
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
um per year and they're you know that
that price just keeps growing as as you
add more things to production
staging test results do not always match
production test results so imagine
you're testing a feature in staging
let's say you're you know you're a
developer and you you you you
um you're building this feature and you
deploy it to staging and you test it in
staging and you worked so hard to make
sure that it works and you
um you go to staging to test it you went
through you know the documentation with
the product owner you worked with you
know other developers to fix any bugs
that you had you worked with the test
engineer all of your end-to-end tests
that you wrote are passing and staging
you feel so good
and you sign off on the feature you're
like yes this looks great and then you
launch the feature to production and
what happens there's a bug so these
environments are so different plain and
simple like the
the test results that you get from
staging a lot of times will not match
production and this is like
you know what every test engineer goes
through when you're testing in staging
versus production
so production includes data that staging
doesn't have and you're never going to
know the differences between your
staging and production environments
until you test and prod
no one cares if staging is broken so
picture this you are testing a high
priority fix for for something that
needs to go out and you log into staging
to test it but staging is down of course
you get the 404 screen of death so you
ping the devops guy but he's not
answering so you ping your manager but
like she's at lunch and then she tells
you to open an IT ticket and then your
manager has to like escalate this ticket
for you and meanwhile you're just trying
to fix this high priority ticket you're
just trying to you know get get your
your feature working again
and no one seems to care so no one's
going to get a call in the middle of
Thanksgiving dinner if staging is down
like nobody cares
the load and staging does not match
production so when you think of the
number of people who use staging versus
the number of people who use production
the difference of that is a lot right
and so because the load is different the
accuracy of like speed and lag times is
going to be different a lot of times
when you write end-to-end tests you have
to add like you know wait for 10 seconds
for this thing to appear or like sleep
for five seconds or 20 seconds for like
this other thing to happen right but
like your users aren't going to wait for
20 seconds for a button to appear like
that's not that's not reality
um okay so the last reason is
configuration drift so
let's say you get paged one night
because there's an incident for your
mobile application and you look at the
logs you identify what the issue is and
in order to fix the issue you have to
make a configuration change in
production so you go to production you
make the configuration change and you go
back to sleep because it's like the
middle of the night but even though
you've fixed the issue you've just
created an even bigger divide between
your staging and production environments
because you didn't make the same change
in your staging environment so a lot of
times staging and production grow
farther and farther apart because of
these changes made during Incident
Management and that's called
configuration drift
and at the end of the day I've never
heard anyone speak highly of their
testing environment except for like the
three of you who think that your staging
environment is the same as production
and I know what you're thinking like
what could go wrong you're testing
improv like it's all fine but what's the
first thing you do right after you
deploy a feature to production
you go to production and you test it
right
okay so why isn't everyone doing this
like
if if if this is such a great practice
and this is like a well-known you know
thing that people do like I had never
heard of it before but if this is
something that makes such a big
difference like why isn't every company
doing this
so companies don't test in prod because
of fear and this lack of trust in their
systems and that's why they don't invest
in the tools and process changes that
are going to generate that trust
so this is a really risky process if you
don't do it correctly so I'm going to
walk you through how to set this up
together we're going to go through all
the steps of testing and prod we're
going to go through all the tools
um
and yeah let's uh let's do that
so the first step to testing in prod is
to install the necessary tools and the
first tool you need is is kind of the
foundation of testing prod it's feature
flagging
and so feature flagging is a way to
decide who sees which features it's used
to hide enable or disable features at
runtime so basically what this means is
you're separating code deployment from
feature release so just because you
deploy code and you deploy it to
production doesn't mean that that
feature is live for everybody to see you
can control that so this is kind of
what it looks like so your developers
would create a feature flag from the UI
and then Target all of your internal
teammates
so this includes
developers QA product design your
automation Bots and I'll I'll touch on
this in a minute so anything related to
the feature can only be seen by these
users that are inside of the feature
flag everything else if you're not in
the feature flag you don't see anything
related to those changes you don't see
anything related to that feature because
you're not in the feature flag you're
not targeted none of your business
so if there happens to be a bug in your
feature it has no impact on those end
users it has no impact on the people who
are not in the feature flag because
they're not targeted
and they don't have access to it
so while the feature flag is off this is
where you go in and you test everything
this is where you check all of the
functionality you go through all of the
requirements you make sure everything is
working while you have access to it
while the feature flag is off
and then once you know your feature is
working in production you turn the flag
on already knowing my feature is working
in production it didn't break anything
that was existing and now I can turn the
feature flag on and I already know that
it works and now your users are you know
happy because you released a feature
without any bugs
and then you repeat this process for
every new feature so each feature has
its own feature flag
and it can be overwhelming when you're
testing in parallel with different
feature Flags you know sometimes
features
um
sometimes features have parts that are
you know maybe one feature affects
another feature maybe it's an update or
maybe you know something happens that
um you need to have more than one
feature flag for a specific feature
because there's different uh settings or
different configurations so it can be
tricky to to decide which sets of flags
to test
um what I would recommend is working
with your product owner to prioritize
what the different combinations of
feature flags are that you need to test
and choose them what choose the most
important flows so this means like if
you have you know a hundred feature
Flags you want to make sure that you
test the right combinations you want to
make sure that you keep up to date and
remove the feature Flags once you're
done with them which we'll talk about
and you want to make sure that your
automation Bots are all maintained
correctly that nobody goes in to delete
them from your feature flagging UI and
I'll show you that too so it can be
overwhelming when you have a lot of
feature Flags but maintenance is like a
big key here
okay so I'm going to walk you through
how to do this
um this the tool that I'm using right
now is split
um full disclosure I used to work for
split but I don't care which feature
flagging tool you use there's launch
Darkly there's Cloud bees there's a
hundred feature flagging tools I'm not
here to like sell you a product I'm here
to teach you about testing products so
use whatever tool you want this is what
it looks like in split
um okay so the first thing you have to
do is create your feature flag and this
is
this is what it looks like in Split
um the first thing you do is you name
your feature flag and then this is the
name that you include in your code
um which I'll show you in the next slide
and then the traffic type defines what
differentiates the people who see your
feature and the people who don't see
your feature so you can say you know
this is this
um this feature is only for like iOS
users or this feature is only for people
in Europe or this feature is for
whatever you want I like to do it by
users so that I can control who sees the
feature and who doesn't very
specifically
and then once you create the feature
flag you set up your targeting rules and
again your targeting rules Define who
sees your feature and who doesn't so
here I'm saying if you're in this list
you can see the feature you have access
to the feature and notice that the test
user is inside of the feature flag so in
this case this robot
is targeted in the feature flag so when
this robot runs the automation test it's
going to log in it's going to have
access to the feature it's going to run
everything and I do this while the
feature flag is off because this way the
the robot is going to catch any bugs
before I turn the feature flag on
and then in the code you say if the user
is in this feature flag give them
treatment on or else give them treatment
off
and then in the this is what the test
looks like so you know you log in with
this test user you go to this page do
whatever actions you need to do perform
whatever test you need to perform and
you're going to expect that feature to
work because this user has access and if
this fails it means you know you caught
a bug and I I also just wanna while I'm
on this topic
a lot of times when tests fail you know
you think oh you know it's just there's
something wrong with the test or
something wasn't you know updated
correctly or
um you know it's it works like that it
fails sometimes
um I just want to say there's no such
thing as a flaky test like if your test
is failing it means something's wrong so
in production when you're testing in
prod that that goes like 10x there
really is no such thing as a flaky test
if you're running something if you're
running a test and it fails something's
wrong go fix it maybe you're not waiting
long enough for something maybe
there's actually a problem maybe there's
actually a bug that your test cut so
no such thing as flaky tests
okay so the oh
have a little pop-up hold on snooze
okay the cherry on top of this cake is
that when you turn on your feature flag
um in production you already know that
your features are working right so
there's no surprises it really is like
the worst feeling in the world when like
you spent so much time testing something
and staging and then you know you feel
so good about it you spent so much time
and then you deploy it to production and
there's a problem like that is the worst
feeling as a test engineer as as a
developer as as you know anyone in that
process like that's not a good feeling
so this this kind of takes care of that
okay so the next tool after feature
flagging that you need is an automation
framework
um I think this is pretty
self-explanatory but it's not scalable
to test everything manually so you're
going to need an automation framework
one that's easy to adopt easy to debug
one that has good reporting one that has
a good support community
and I'll go through some of my oh that's
interesting I'll go through some of my
favorites um
in a little bit
okay the next tool you need is a job
scheduler and the job schedule is just
going to run the test for you so you can
do this as a chrome job like you know
every hour like run these tests in prod
or you can do it through something like
Jenkins that will
you know run the test for you on on
every build this is totally customizable
the next tool you need is an alerting
tool and you want to choose an alerting
tool that can be integrated with your
job scheduler so when a test fails
someone gets alerted
it's important that everybody on your
team from product to design to
engineering is on call for when tests
fail because everybody on the team owns
product quality it's not just the test
engineer's responsibility to make sure
that your products your features are
working so make sure that that
everybody's on call
these are some of the tools that I've
used for testing in prod I don't care
what tools you use these are the ones
that I've used that I recommend
they're I don't have anything specific
to say about any of these except that
for your automation framework I really
like Robot Framework I don't know if you
guys have used it before but it's like a
um
it's a python-based
keyword driven automation framework that
I love they're not like sponsoring me or
anything yet but I am obsessed with
Robot Framework so if you haven't if
you're brand new to automation or
testing or any of that like robot is
definitely the way to go
um split and launch Darkly either
the same thing harness has harness has
feature flagging Cloud Beast has on
job scheduling I mean those these are
literally all the same alerting I
suggest using like two or three
different alerting tools at the same
time because you can use one for like
okay 9-1-1 something's wait in England
is it 9-1-1 or is it what is it
one one nine oh nine nine nine that's
okay
um
you know 999 something's wrong
um or you know if if everything's
passing and all the tests work and
everything then you can do
you know like a slack message like
everything's fine move on
okay so after you have all of your tools
installed you need to create your test
data
and so the the problem is and this is
where a lot of people get scared because
you're actually you are creating test
data in production so you need a way to
create and manipulate test data in
production without affecting real end
users or any data and Analytics
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a consistent naming convention
for our test users and this is something
like a Boolean right like is test user
is true or is test is true something
where that's specific for these test
users that you're creating and these
test users like like the robot that I
that I put into the feature flag they
act like real users they look like real
users but only we would be able to
interact with them so everything that
happens with this person is test user
equals true gets put into a different
database or in this other table or you
know there's this other place in your
datadog dashboard that like all the data
goes there or you know you have some way
to separate them because of this Boolean
because of this specific thing and it
doesn't have to be this Boolean it can
be something else but this is something
that you and your team can decide on
together
um and this way you can differentiate
between people's real interactions and
your test interactions and
the the most important thing here is you
need to follow these specific
predetermined guidelines and your your
entire team needs to agree on them so if
you decide like we're going to do is
test user equals true that means
um you know all of your business
stakeholders need to know like
everything that has this is test user
equals true is going to go in this other
database it's not going to be looked at
for like business decisions it's not
going to be looked at for anything else
besides like testing purposes
okay next you need to write your tests I
like bdd because it's just simple to to
to read and write
um you know given one then like broken
cucumber it works really well with Robot
Framework
um there's a lot of times when you're
writing your tests there's third parties
like it's very rare that you will write
an end-to-end test that is only within
your uh your platform your products
there's many times there's you know
external third parties like payment
providers there's
um you know a bunch of e-commerce tools
there's different different third
parties that can be integrated within
your your product
um and so when I'm handling third
parties what's best for me is to have a
header in the API request that you send
to the third party and then work with
them and say hey any requests that you
get from this header is going to be for
a test and I want you to handle it
differently like do this other thing put
it over here like don't process this or
do X Y and Z and I've done this a few
times and I've never had a problem
um
but yeah I would put that in the API
request
another part of writing your tests is
the setup and tear down and this I think
is more important than the test itself
especially when you're testing in prod
so what in your setup you want to clear
cookies log in as the test User make
sure that you're starting from a blank
slate then you perform the test right
you you validate all the functionality
you make sure that the feature is
working
then in the tear down you undo
everything that you're tested you know
make sure you clean up that test data
and then if any step fails you get
alerted immediately and the tests stop
so this is this is um one of those one
of those things that is a little might
be a little bit different than like a
normal test Suite is that when a test
fails in production it's a problem like
go fix it it's not oh you know that test
sometimes fails and it's fine
um no that that doesn't happen
okay next the next step is to deploy to
a production Canary so production
canaries allow you to slowly roll out a
change to a small subset of users before
you roll it out to the entire population
and what this does is it minimizes the
impact if something goes wrong so let's
say that
you turn on the feature flag and you
know there's a problem like something
happened where you didn't catch the bug
you didn't
um
there was a bug and you know you didn't
see it and then you turn on the feature
flag and now you have this issue in
production so
if that happens would you want a hundred
percent of your users to encounter that
issue or one percent so this is adding
that layer of risk mitigation so even
after you turn on the feature flag you
can say hey turn it on for just five
percent of the population or one percent
or whatever you want and if there is an
issue you can identify it roll back to a
better version and then fix the issue in
this controlled environment and when
you're ready turn the feature flag back
on
um and something I suggest just due to
like its sensitivity is that
infrastructure and configuration changes
should always be released with a canary
um this is what it looks like to set up
a canary it's just like this little
toggle and you can say you know one
percent five percent
um of people
okay so to summarize risk mitigation
before launch use feature Flags to
Target your users after launch use
production canaries to limit your
audience in case something does go wrong
thirdly I would say using a a test an
AAA Test is when you give your users
both inside and outside of the feature
flag the same experience and so what
that does is that allows you to build
your confidence in the feature flagging
system and this is great if you've never
used feature Flags before because you
can make sure that the data on both
sides is the same
next I would say start small so like
you're not going to start out with like
your most complex flow and say yeah
that's the one I'm going to start with
in production please don't do that you
know start out with like the simplest
thing you can like a small CSS change
like something that you know doesn't
matter if it breaks because
it's it's it's small start small and
then and then grow
so the outcome of this is that we had
higher confidence we had increased
developer velocity
um
your your developers and your your team
they're going to spend less time fixing
bugs and defects and more time creating
new features more time spent on you know
more deliverables because your bugs and
defects are going to be found so much
sooner in the testing life cycle
testing and prod promotes a very
proactive engineering culture so as a
test engineer like I don't want to wait
until something breaks have a user
report it to me go figure out what it is
try to recreate it and then report it
back to my team as a bug like I want to
fix any issues before anyone ever knows
anything is wrong like I want to be
proactive about it I don't want to wait
until something breaks and then go in
and fix it
so there's always people who are like I
just can't test in prod it's not an
option
I can't do it my company is like
the government and it's impossible so in
this case if that's you like if you
really there's just zero way you can
spin up a containerized environment you
can use something like Docker to just
you know create a copy of prod test
there and then get rid of the
environment like spin up an environment
per build that's an option
it's it's a good option if you're not
able to test in prod it's just not as
good again because it is a copy of
product it isn't actually production so
a lot of you'll still have some of the
same issues but it does that that copy
happens in like right before you run the
test versus whenever your staging
environment was created or updated
okay so if this is something that you
want to do a lot of times like the
hardest part of this is to shift your
company's testing culture
um so if this is something you want to
do explain why the pros outweigh the
cons to your management so is your
staging environment unreliable yes it is
except for apparently you three
use examples from the past so like do
you remember when we merged this thing
to prod and it broke and it took down
our whole system but it was like working
in in staging
and then propose a path forward like I
know a lot of the feature flagging tools
have a free version that you can use so
like split and launch dark we both have
it where you can just start using
feature flags for free so that's
something that you can do
and this this is this part is really
funny because
a lot of times like people are so scared
to deploy new features especially like
whether to deploy on Fridays and I I was
in the speaker room the speaker the
speaker lounge and
um one of the speakers goes oh I just
got this request for someone to deploy
at 4 pm on a Friday like how could they
do that like it's so late and I'm like
if you're testing in prod like it's fine
just deploy your code at any time like
do whatever you want you don't have to
like this fear of like I can't deploy
on Friday like I have to wait until you
know Monday morning like you don't have
those discussions anymore when you're
testing in prod like that you you have
so much more confidence in in your
releases
okay
so we're almost done
um
there's always going to be these like
negative nancies these people who are
like Talia like go back go back to LA
like this is this is never gonna work
um and to those people I say three
things one staging will never fully
represent prod like I don't care how
much work you put into your staging
environment it's never going to be an
exact replica of production it's a sunk
cost you're putting money into something
that again is never going to be an exact
replica and these people are not my
target audience like the the person who
I'm picturing here like this person has
been at the company for 20 years like in
their cubicle and they don't like change
and they if that's you I'm sorry this
presentation is not for you
um but yeah there's always going to be
people who don't like this change who
don't like this Innovation
um
tough I don't know
testing prod is like it's an Innovative
thing it's like an upcoming like
emerging solution and so if if this is
something that you are not open to and I
haven't convinced you at all that this
is a good idea
um
then you should tell me that
um okay so to summarize the steps of
testing in Broad
the first thing you have to do is
install your tools so this is your
feature flagging and automation
framework your job schedule your
alerting tool create your test data and
make sure your test entities only
interact with each other so like if you
have a test user they log in and then
they click on this like test button and
they do this other like everything that
is in that flow needs to be marked as
like a test instance
then you write your test you make sure
your tear down cleans up your test you
launch behind a feature flag deploy to a
production Canary and have a drink
because you're testing abroad
okay if you haven't been paying
attention at all for the past 40 minutes
I want you to take away two things one
no one cares if your feature is working
in staging we care if it works in
production
and the only way to know if it's working
in prod is to test it in prod
okay thank you everybody
um
I can take questions now if anyone has
questions yeah
instructions login to
sort of introduction it goes production
in all honestly we don't desperate okay
if if the logs say the lawyers we're
okay so we have no choice because of
that that must be common so someone
solve this that you're not you're not
able to get a test user to log in like
you can't create that process
yeah so this is something that I would
work with like your I.T people with to
see if like there's a way to do it and a
lot of times if you convince someone in
like
um like your VPS or your higher ups that
like you this is something that you want
to start doing there are ways to do it
like I used to work for a financial
company and you can create fake bank
accounts in prod they just have to be
marked a certain way they're going to
give you a really hard time about it and
you know you're gonna have to fight a
little bit but it is possible there's
there's no like one solution for every
company too like if you really can't log
in there's no way for you to create test
data you can do this in something like
Docker or something where you have like
a containerized build and you can log in
with something like that
yeah
anything else
okay happy Friday